- [Kris Maher] I've been in
East Palestine this week,
talking to residents who
were forced to evacuate
after a derailment of a
Norfolk Southern train
on February 3rd.
Residents were told that
they could return home.
But since they've been back,
many have concerns about
being back in their homes,
and they're concerned about smells
and the potential for health effects
from chemicals that were
released during the derailment.
Right now, there's sort of,
just this kind of cloud of concern
that's hanging over the town.
(wind chimes ring)
(soft staccato music)
On Friday, February 3rd, around 9 p.m.,
a Norfolk Southern train derailed
in the small village of
East Palestine, Ohio,
which is on the border with Pennsylvania.
As soon as the derailment occurred,
police and other officials
came through the town
and told people that they
had to evacuate immediately.
(sirens blaring)
Monday, February 6th, Norfolk Southern
said that it would have
to breach five tanker cars
containing vinyl chloride,
to prevent a potentially
catastrophic explosion.
- I honestly feel that the Palestine,
the police department,
the fire department,
all the first responders,
they don't have the answers to give us
because I don't think they know.
They're not getting the
straight answers either.
- [Kris] Residents in East
Palestine and surrounding areas
packed the school gymnasium
Wednesday night to seek answers.
- We're trying to get
information out to our citizens.
Everybody's concerned, I'm concerned.
But, you know, it's not
Norfolk Southern here.
It's the EPA, the people who
have been working with us,
trying to get our citizens
back into their homes safe.
- We find it very hard to believe
that there is no particulate map.
- It was just a big runaround.
Like, I feel like a lot of
the questions that were asked
were people's rantings,
and just speaking in circles.
The answers that were given
were things that we've already been told.
- [Kris] Norfolk Southern
declined to send representatives
to the town hall, citing safety concerns.
The railroad said it has
distributed $1.5 million directly
to more than 1,000 families,
and some businesses,
and has established a $1 million fund
available immediately to the community.
One of the chemicals released
in the train derailment
was vinyl chloride,
which the National Cancer Institute says
is associated with a higher
risk of liver cancer.
Federal and state environmental regulators
say they're going to continue
to monitor the air quality
and water in the area,
to ensure that it's safe for citizens.
- What we have discovered
through the testing and
sampling that's been done
is that very early on,
you know, we have estimated,
based on our sampling and
modeling, about 3500 dead fish
across that space,
across those streams,
tributaries, waterways.
- [Kris] The administrator
for the US Environmental Protection Agency
visited Thursday.
- Let me be clear.
EPA will exercise
our oversight
and our enforcement
authority under the law
to be sure we are getting the results
that the community deserves.
- [Kris] So far, the EPA has said
that air monitoring has
showed no levels of concern
from chemicals released into the air.
The EPA has also said
that the water is safe to
drink in East Palestine
from the municipal water facility.
- This is so much bigger
than just it in the water.
Our environment, our wildlife animals,
our farmers that have
to till their soil up.
- [Kris] Many residents want
testing inside their homes,
which is being done.
But even when it is being done,
they're still kind of distrustful
about those results at this point.
(soft staccato music)